when it comes to diet
things can get complicated
especially in the context of whether a
diet may have anti-aging potential
diet includes not only composition but
abundance and timing and if you think
about it even a specific diet can have
much variation in each of these
different variables depending on your
lifestyle and why the food you eat was
sourced
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video with
the help of an interesting recent review
article that you should totally check
out if you can
i will explain the different diets
including intermittent fasting fasting
mimicking diets ketogenic diets
time-restricted feeding and protein
restriction
and see what are the most and least
promising of these as anti-aging diets
at least based on the current
information
and then we'll look at what is it about
these diets that have led them to being
described as anti-aging
what's the evidence and what are the
remaining questions
and as well i will include some common
misconceptions about diets so you'll
want to hang around until then
so just a little terminology first
before we start what exactly do we mean
by anti-aging hair well here we're
referring to anti-aging as delaying or
reversing biological aging by targeting
established molecular mechanisms of
aging so that's what we mean now in
terms of the scientific research into
anti-aging diets it could probably be
best traced back to the early 1900s when
rodent studies examined the impact of
caloric restriction
caloric restriction here refers to the
reduction in total calories by 20 to 50
percent without
malnutrition reducing the amount of food
given to lab breads rats delayed their
development but it increased their adult
lifespan
and as you may already know caloric
restriction or dietary restriction has
also been shown to extend lifespan in
many different muscle organisms
but what about humans
well one dataset
includes the cleverly named
comprehensive assessment of long-term
effects of reducing intake of energy
calorie
this was a series of clinical trials
involving calorie restriction here 25
and both normal and overweight adults
ranging from a few months to two years
what they observed was a variety of
clinical biomarkers including decreased
weight enhanced insulin sensitivity and
glucose tolerance and improvements in
cardiometabolic risk factors however as
we'll see later it's not quite plain
saline caloric restriction but for now
let's move on to the other diets
so next up are keto diets these diets
involve a restriction in carbohydrates
and are higher in fats to induce ketosis
simply puts this is when you don't burn
carbohydrates to generate energy but
instead break down fats into ketones and
use them as an energy source
support for this diet and anti-aging
comes from two 2017 papers you can see
here
this second paper had mice either in a
12 carbohydrate diet or a one percent
carbohydrate diet
from 12 months of age in both there was
an increase in median lifespan along
with improvements in memory and motor
function
then we have intermittent fasting and
fasting mimicking diets
now i have separate videos on these
diets which you can find the link to in
the description so i only briefly
mentioned them here
and so fasting mimicking diets fmds were
coined by dr foltalongo as an
alternative intervention to caloric
restriction mainly to avoid the risk of
malnourishment
and it involves a reduced caloric diet
but only for a short period every few
months and it's thought to work in a
similar fame to both caloric restriction
and keto diets by inducing ketosis
however one of the interesting things
with these intermittent fasting
approaches is that there's a combination
of having the fasting periods with a
period of re-feeding which at least in
radiant models seems to show that the
re-feeding can induce stem cell
activation however a recent study showed
that alternate day fasting over three
weeks in healthy people was less
effective than having an isocaloric
daily energy restriction
and it showed no benefits for measures
of metabolic regulation or
cardiovascular health however most of
these studies in humans are really
lacking long-term analyses at the moment
and then there is time-restricted
feeding which as suggested by the name
is when you can eat every day just
within a specified time window
not only has this been shown to improve
metabolic parameters in mice such as
glucose and insulin homeostasis but it
also promotes and maintains intrinsic
circadian rhythms
one of the challenges though with these
studies are mice as with the other
intermittent strategies it's ensuring
that the mice eat equivalent amounts of
food to control mice and in the case of
time-restricted feeding that they don't
eat all the food at once but throughout
the time window
as discussed in this review although
there is some promising data from the
mouse studies human data is less clear
partly due to sparsity and also because
it might depend on when the eating
window was for example morning
thursday's evening
and lastly there are diets low in
protein
there's evidence from braden's studies
to support lifespan increase however in
rats protein restriction resulted in a
15 increased median lifespan whilst rats
that underwent caloric restriction had
50 increase
however in support another study has
shown that a low protein to carbohydrate
ratio also resulted in a longer lifespan
so here health was optimized when
protein was replaced with carbohydrates
however the same study showed that mice
with greater median lifespan actually
had relatively high protein
and so given that human analyses have
also shown that over the age of 65
reducing protein intake was associated
with higher mortality the picture is
clearly incomplete
part of this may come from protein
quality that is the amino acids present
that make up the protein there are
plenty different amino acids that can be
used to make proteins
and so the reason i mentioned this is
because separate studies have shown that
reducing just specific amino acids
notably branch-chain amino acids have
been shown to increase lifespan and
delay age-related frailty in white and
flies
so how do all these diets compare
well to bring together the information
we've covered so far take a look at this
table from the review
the table summarizes lifespan effects in
studies and rodents with the number of
arrows indicating the relative
robustness and consistency of reported
effects
you can pause and take the time to read
these sections but ultimately it seems
to show so far that low calorie
interventions are superior to isocaloric
diets
the thing is though i am not a mouse and
neither are you
hopefully
and the other thing you have to consider
is that these muscle organisms are kept
consistently on a diet whilst for us
there will be occasions where we modify
our diet and change our eating patterns
so extrapolating from mouse data is
unsurprisingly not the easiest thing to
do another interesting aspect to point
out is the how are these diets supposed
to be working
we've already mentioned ketosis but
another signaling pathway important to
mediating many if not all of these diet
interventions is mtor signaling mtor
signaling can be activated by sensing
amino acids within a cell and as you can
see in this diagram these different diet
interventions are thought to reduce mtor
signaling and thereby aid in the
activation of repair pathways such as
autophagy enhanced mitochondrial
function
improved stem cell function and
inhibition of protein synthesis and
senescence-associated inflammation
and this is also the bit where i remind
you that rapamycin which inhibits mtor
is often referred to as a caloric
restriction memetic as it's ultimately
acting through a similar pathway
albeit with diet as it's also got things
like ketosis going on these are by no
means exactly the same mechanism now
before you hear my verdict and future
work ideas i thought it'd be good to
include some of the fact from fiction
that's also included in this review
firstly that caloric restriction always
works
this isn't quite the case and although
we don't necessarily understand why they
haven't always worked it seems likely
that it's dependent on sex genetic
background level of restriction and
other unidentified variables a second
statement is individual macronutrients
are good or bad for aging
firstly the evidence is still unclear
regarding this but more importantly we
still need protein fats and
carbohydrates to live so i don't think
you should consider any of them alone
being bad
and then lastly anti-aging diets are
known to slow aging in people well no
there isn't any strong evidence to
support this in humans at the moment and
not even in muscle organisms such as
mice
so clearly questions remain
but generally it seems eating less and
reducing amateur activation
seems currently the most likely
anti-aging diet but clearly important
questions remain
one really important factor to
understand is how genetic and
environmental variation modified the
diet response especially in understudy
populations
this also goes beyond the surface level
of like food allergies
which should already tell you that there
can't be one universal anti-aging diet
but it enters the realm of precision
nutrition the idea that each of us will
ultimately have a diet that is best for
us
for example as written in this article
there is a very real likelihood that any
given caloric restriction like diet
could enhance longevity in some people
while shortening lifespan on others and
the second important point is in the
context of environmental challenges for
example viruses and flus
adds there are concerns that dietary
restriction may put you at risk of
having a weaker immune system
and the fact i have to use words like
mei further demonstrates that research
in these areas in terms of human studies
is really lacking
to address these issues the ideal
experiment would be to just randomize
thousands of people to these different
diets for multiple decades however this
is very impractical and expensive and
also probably unethical
so we have to use more observational
studies and and these include
co-founding factors such as wealth
social status general interest in health
as well as genetics
and so it's very hard to
distinguish cause and effect
and so whilst i'm still probably an
advocate for eating earlier in the day
even if the data is still inconclusive
evidently not overeating and being
mindful about reducing protein and sugar
intake seems like the most reasonable
take home from the data
at so to end i will steal the quake from
the review future research directed at
clarifying the underlying mechanisms
involved in eliciting the longevity
promoting response to caloric
restriction and how this differs amongst
individuals should one day help us to
realize a true position during science
approach so with that i hope this video
has given some clarification about these
different diets
but also highlighted the areas where we
still need to do much more research so
with that i want to say thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening